food prices are on the rise in Tripoli
before the start of Ramadan residents
are rushing to markets fearing some
commodities might try now at during the
holy month of fasting Musa Aziza is
checking what he can afford to buy in
this butcher shop like many other
Libyans he has not received his salary
for the past three months
we are following austerity measures in
our houses by downsizing the amount of
commodities we need to consume the
government has not intervened to stop
shop owners from increasing prices the
value of the Libyan dinars falling and
banks are running short of hard
currencies because of the halt in oil
exports despite the dramatic fall in oil
prices globally oil revenues remain the
backbone of Libya's economy almost 30
percent of Libya's six million people
rely on estate salaries with the closure
of oil installations because of
continuing the fighting between rival
groups many fear a worsening financial
crisis for the past three months forces
loyal to warlord Khalifa Haftar have
been blocking the oil terminals in the
east of the country production has
dropped from 1.2 million to less than a
hundred thousand barrels per day the
state oil firm estimates it is lost
around three and half billion dollars in
revenue meanwhile half there is one year
battle to capture the capital goes on
that has taken a toll on people and
infrastructure consequences might remain
for years to come a lot of factories
have been affected by the war on Tripoli
because many of them are located near
the fighting areas also many investment
projects that were signed with foreign
companies have now been frozen this war
is not only affecting economy in Tripoli
but across the whole country
Musa and many other Libyans are worried
if the blockade on the oil facilities
continues the economic crisis will get
even worse they're wondering when and
how their situation will
of Mahmoud Abdul Wahid al jazeera
Tripoli